wow
are you in lebron
[Music]
watching people fall is funny when last
time you really fell
oh like one of those oh no no
hey shaq when you fall during the games
it's the funniest [ __ ] i've ever seen in
my life
hey you ever see his legs after he fall
next time look i'm telling you let's say
i watch the game but he falls exactly
dude look
it's always something stupid like he go
up to get a rebound he don't get oh no
[Laughter]
[Applause]
hey lebron this is lebron look at that
come on god damn it [ __ ] get your ass
[ __ ] man get up you know you know
[Applause]
hey
look okay one more one more jack
this is how you fall in front of me no
oh god please
holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
oh y'all gotta look at the coach face
y'all don't watch the right [ __ ] man
look this [ __ ] falling mr coach
somebody help his ass up lebron
get it up
[Music]
no no no i pushed him too hard
i don't know why i ever got at lebron
last year you know because he he went
from the most beloved player to the most
hated because he left cleveland and went
to miami i'm a comedian i travel
every week i've been to cleveland been
to miami not a tough decision
yesterday where i want to live
that's not asking some dude hey man
who'd you rather [ __ ] beyonce or
precious
uh amazon beyonce you go beyonce on this
one yeah i go beyonce
but precious razor you grew up with
precious i wanna [ __ ] princess no more
[Applause]
i saw this documentary on lebron two
called more than a game they had us he
they had his high school coach on there
and his mom was on there and they said
lebron
was raised by a single mother in akron
ohio and then interviewed his high
school coach and
his high school coaches like you know if
lebron would have had a dad in his life
his game
would be at a whole nother level i said
i don't think so i think lebron's better
because he didn't have a dad in his life
cause lebron's got
like a broken home type of game because
you could tell that some pen up
aggression
come from somewhere when he's on the
court cause he'd be dribbling hard
passing hard dunking hard where the [ __ ]
is my dad mom
[ __ ] god damn
you ever see kobe bryant kobe had a mom
and dad bounce pass layup hey dad
[Applause]
with just two games left before the
playoffs kobe
bryant received a technical foul and
uttered this phrase
after returning to the bench
now hold on in trophy's defense he was
referring to thai referee
faux king fight
[Music]
[Applause]
falcon begut
thailand's most famous referee
kogi has apologized to the ref and to
the nba
and must find a hundred thousand dollars
he has also told the gay community that
he has nothing but respect for them
and reminded them that he shares their
affection for spirited rounds of anal
sex
[Applause]
so just to review the gay community was
insulted
by this guy
[Applause]
it does seem odd that just a year ago
kobe was so comfortable with his
sexuality that he posed for the los
angeles times magazine with this picture
but i guess one photo
isn't a big deal i don't know what the
other oh
[Applause]
lawrence of gay arabia
the french lieutenant shooting guard
now i don't want a homophobic slur
hurled out at me
but who wears white after labor day
the lakers won dominating fashion
game six was dominating game five jimmy
butler did his thing again
oh beautiful and then game six the
lakers were just not having it
on not having it we're not having it
brian said i'm locking up jimmy the
whole game yep
they did their [ __ ] thing um
after lebron and lakers win lebron is
being interviewed by rachel nichols or
whoever it is
and he says i want my respect
i want my damn respect i want my damn
respect too
yeah but he really just said respect
everybody else so he's just so he can
say that
get the [ __ ] out of here not rob lowe
that's all you are to me is not blah
blah blah
blah dude [ __ ] outta here nobody respect
you lebron want his damn respect now
why do you think he said that i think he
wants to be
the goat i don't think he's there yet
he's not
do you believe that he believes he is
and then how is he justifying that to
himself
so in other words you're lebron james
you believe you're the goat
you don't have six rings how are you
justifying you're better than jordan
with what you've done i think you always
and whatever you do you have to believe
you are a little better than you really
are
whatever what do you think he's doing i
think i never had a phil jackson as a
coach i never had a great coach
i don't even know if i've ever he's ever
had a good coach spoelstra early in his
career but spoelstra wasn't what he is
now
yeah then uh he thinks i never had
scottie pippen i had some good teammates
but now i finally got my pippin dwayne
wade was really
good that first year then when we
finally won the championship starting
then
he would get hurt every playoffs okay i
think he thinks
i was around nf to ask cleveland for
years of the organization [ __ ] up
everything
so and i came back against arguably the
greatest team ever seventy three and
nine
everyone fair to say your argument is
he thinks he did more with less yes well
said
okay he cut that down way better than i
did i did what you usually do
no no doubt sick dude yeah no synergy so
it's humbling isn't it yeah i hate it
when you do that [ __ ] to me even though
i love
like i'd be saying the longest rant and
you're just like yeah a plus b
did i just do math with letters
i thought i killed it too and then he
was like more with less i was like
he did more with less so your point is
more with less which i think is a great
argument i think there's also something
said
to be said with him doing with three
different organizations
i think people sleep on that every new
organization you go to you gotta build a
new team
granted the bulls built two teams
technically right right
but it's the same organization and the
same key players
lebron had to go do this again in
cleveland
build the whole team around him again
with the lakers yeah
we could say it's easy because you're
lebron everybody wants to play with you
but it's not that easy
right getting everybody to have the same
chemistry establishing the culture
getting a coach that's going to run the
culture that you want to have there
yeah it's not like the lakers have
culture no right the lake
doesn't have culture l.a doesn't have
culture right the
the lakers were kobe and then when kobe
left there was just a giant void yeah to
be filled
right yeah so i think that's a really
interesting argument
and i think that he and especially with
the 3-1 [ __ ] he might go no i don't
think jordan could do that
and i would agree because i don't think
jordan would let himself go down
3-1 right but that being said
there are there is a solid argument for
his goat
ship if you will
i don't think he's there nope i think
he's actually
two more rings away yeah
in my opinion i think in order to be
spoken about with jordan you need the
six
but i think as far as our generation
goes
he's number two and it's not close yeah
i think there used to be close number
twos for our generation we didn't see
wilt
yeah we didn't see bill russell right we
didn't see those [ __ ]
but we didn't see karim no
we didn't even see magic really didn't
see magic or bird really we're bird
yeah but we saw kobe we saw
jordan and we saw lebron and i think
that we can all unanimously say
number two yeah is lebron yeah
and if that wasn't solidified before
within our generation again not the old
heads within our generation
i think this solidifies yeah i i did see
some [ __ ] this weeks with someone saying
kobe bryant
had five [ __ ] rings so if he gets one
next year
he gets number six then you have to say
that he's on par with jordan
as far as championships yes we can all
do math
but as far as him ever eclipsing michael
jordan he never will
and i'm gonna i'm gonna tell you this
right now not only will he never eclipse
michael jordan he's not even
[ __ ] close and i know what all you
laker fans are thinking
but wait a minute [ __ ] he's doing the
same [ __ ] moves
yes he is yes he is
physically he can do what michael jordan
can do
yes he can all right but this is the
difference
michael jordan created those [ __ ]
moves all right you can find a guitarist
in your [ __ ] neighborhood who can
play voodoo child
does that mean they're as good as jimi
hendrix who wrote the [ __ ] song
who was 20 years ahead of his [ __ ]
any other
guitarist on the planet
look as great as stevie ray vaughan is i
love that guy to death
he can't touch he can't [ __ ] touch
jimi hendrix he can't hendricks came up
with that [ __ ]
and then [ __ ] stevie ray modernized
it but it was jimmy [ __ ]
you know what i mean
it's like a pilot taking learns how to
fly and then tries to compare himself
to orville and wilbur wright oh
they they [ __ ] flew only across the
field i'm flying across the whole
country
i'm three thousand miles better than the
people who invented
flying all right
now kobe bryant has the the i think
has the athletic gifts of michael jordan
and if you had the two of them play each
other one-on-one
at the height of their powers it would
be the greatest one-on-one game
ever all right
but as far as the forward thinking the
the
the athletic genius
kobe bryant is not an inventor he isn't
he does have the drive
he's got all that other [ __ ] but he
doesn't have the ability
to take the game 20 years into the
future
where he has no [ __ ] peer
there was no arguments when jordan
played
there was no arguments about who the
best guy in the league was for the last
10 years of his career
there was you know early on before he
established himself you know people you
know
were throwing other names in there but
after you know [ __ ] 89
there was no question who the best
player was
and by [ __ ] 92-93 he was
without a doubt the greatest basketball
player of all time
and he still is kobe bryant on the other
hand
his entire career there's always been
well what about this guy what about that
guy
you know right now is he kobe lebron
james
you know i still give it to kobe kobe is
still
uh beyond lebron james but lebron james
is very close
there was no one near jordan i can't
even explain it to you
it's like when you talk to those [ __ ]
douchebags from the baby boom generation
those selfish [ __ ] who hang their hat
on they stopped the vietnam war
and then became corporate douchebags um
there's a big generalization for you
like they always say like no matter how
much you get into the beatles you just
can't wrap your head around what it was
like when they put out an
album how far ahead they were from
everybody else
it's the same thing with richard pryor
because what happens is as the years go
by
everybody rips those those geniuses off
and everybody gets caught up to where
the [ __ ] they were and what usually
happens is if you're young
you're watching the contemporary people
and then as you go back in time
you go back 30 years you go all the way
back to prior and you see him do
the black guy white guy thing and so
many people have ripped him off
that that the genius of what he does is
is a little tainted you know what i mean
so that's like when people look at kobe
and that and they go back and they look
at jordan
they take for granted
what kobe's doing now because it just
seems
it just like that's what basketball is
now because
jordan showed showed him what was
possible
you understand what the [ __ ] i'm saying
here
i'm sure laker fans won't [ __ ]
they'll they'll argue it
but they're [ __ ] morons anyways
they're going to be like george
kobe's just as good as jordan you know
the same way
they try to claim that they have [ __ ]
16
championships or this other douche who
wrote me this week who tried to say they
have 18.
there's such there's just no way to
respect
a laker fan i just because some they're
just
transplanted [ __ ] dis there's so few
people from los
angeles and what happens is people move
out there
you know hollywood [ __ ] phonies and
then the lakers you know they always
have some [ __ ] amazing team they're a
hell of they're an awesome franchise i
think they're uh they're
wait how many championships they got
since 1980
they won five eight they've won nine
they're better than the yankees since
1980
better than the canadians they are the
franchise
all right so all these [ __ ] [ __ ]
go out there
and they see jack nicholas a uh a
[ __ ] true fan
jack nicholson what the [ __ ] is wrong
with me every time i want to say jack
nicholas i say nicholson
and vice versa there
god help me if they're ever in the same
[ __ ] room
really bill when the [ __ ] would that
happen huh
when you do some corporate gig for some
people who actually did something with
their life
and you go in there like a dancing
monkey and then afterwards try to talk
to them in the green room as they're
clearly
blowing you off um
um anyways the [ __ ] am i talking about
here yeah all those douche bag laker
fans
you know i talked to one the other day
like oh dude i'm die hard i'm die hard
i found out he was from new york how the
[ __ ] do you go from being a knicks fan
to being a lakers fan i'll tell you why
you become a [ __ ] phony how do you
leave new york and move to l.a
how do you do that you know unless
you're in show business which was he
i think he was i can't remember i drank
so much this [ __ ] week all of
everybody's just amalgam
everybody's just a big just amalgamating
if that's even a word into just one big
[Music]
face
[Music]
you